foreign
so I'd like to ask you all a question
that I've pondered for these past few
years
why is it that for-profit organizations
and non-profits or those that work on
the development space are quite
different with the type of impact that
they have
I mean in theory they should be similar
right
they both have access to super talented
individuals
should it matter that you are working on
affordable housing or trying to build a
multi-million dollar Condo building
I don't think it should
but if I took a poll in this room and
asked you all to take a guess on which
of these buildings would be completed
first
I am fairly certain that we'll all agree
it's not the affordable housing
right and you may go well Tolo is it
about the money one of these has access
to more money than the other and I think
there's truth to that but I believe it
goes much deeper than that I live in
Nigeria now before I moved back to
Nigeria I actually spent the book of my
career working in development markets
and in the for-profit sector right
in the for-profit sector we are held
accountable every year by investors to
ensure that the benefits of the
activities that we invested in
throughout the year far outweigh the
investments in those activities
this annual Cadence of accountability
required that everything that we did was
striving toward increased
profitabilities and locate of
accountability create such a high sense
of urgency in everything that we did
and so we leverage data analytics
evidence-based tools to ensure that
we're able to hit this goals fast and in
the development sort of space where I
spend the bulk of my time these days the
culture appears quite different
we don't seem to operate with the same
sense of urgency
the work we are doing now is arguably
more meaningful
right we are trying to solve problems
such as increasing Financial access to
those who currently don't have it we're
trying to solve problems that include
education Access Energy access and in
fact increasingly we are trying to
address help people who are vulnerable
build resilience to climate change
these challenges are quite significant
and required that we do things
differently
in Africa we have a problem which states
that if you want to go fast go alone
if you want to go far go together
but what happens when trying to solve a
problem like increasing Financial access
requires that you go both fast and far
I believe that we need to do development
differently we need to include the
profit motive and for-profit approaches
into the way that we do development
so let me walk you through an example of
how we experimented with this in Nigeria
we're trying to expand Financial access
in Nigeria for those who don't know
Financial access is an individual's
ability to
get access to insurance
or loans or build savings
a lot of research has shown in fact that
a lot of these development activities
that we have require Financial access as
a key enabler
however when you look in Africa we are
lagging behind the rest of the world in
terms of financial access
in fact in sub-Saharan Africa only about
55 percent of our adults have access to
financial services
a country like Nigeria where I live
you have more adults in Nigeria that do
not have access to financial services
then the entire population of Canada
think about that
more individuals in Nigeria do not have
access to financial services then the
entire population of Canada
now I mean this is not for lack of
trying we've been working on this issue
for a while and I think the reason one
of the reasons the issue persists is
because we're trying to solve the
problems in the same way we have tried
to do it in in developed markets trying
to build Bank branches and ATMs
everywhere but this is so expensive and
capital intensive and time intensive
which we cannot afford
but there's a cheaper scalable option
agent banking
with agent banking a financial
institution can hire an individual or a
retailer to provide Financial Services
to the community on their behalf
so you have a
a grocery retailer right she gets cash
from selling her food stuff to her
customers
and she can play the role of a human ATM
if you will
connecting to the branch online and able
to dispense cash to our customers and
other Financial Services
and unlike Bank branches and ATMs you
can deploy an agent within about a day
so you can literally start the day when
the community without Financial access
and at the end of the day with an agent
provide Financial access to that
community
we know agent banking works
and in fact in Nigeria we estimate that
over this past three years was deployed
about 850 thousands of these agents
but the problem persists
after all of this work the problem
persists in like in Nigeria we're still
we still estimate that
uh only about I mean less than 50 in
fact of adults still have access despite
all of this work and this has persisted
for over a decade
so a few colleagues and I decided to
investigate this to try to understand
why is it that after all this work we're
still struggling with this
and so we teamed up with non-profit
organizations and for-profit
organizations to understand after
hundreds of thousands of Agents why does
this problem persist and we discovered
two important problems
one is we're in fact are not deploying
these agents into the right places
the rural parts in Northern parts of
Nigeria most desperately needed these
agents
but the deployment tended to be in the
urban South
and when we deployed them we tended to
also deploy overlapping agents
what does that mean think of this as you
are trying to you know you deploy 50 ATM
ATMs in the in a New York City Block
what's the point of that
in fact if you had used data analytics
perhaps we would have done this properly
the second problem we observed was that
agents in fact were not staying around
for the Long Haul
so you place this agent but the average
agent only remained operational for
about three months
between the startup costs and the
recurring costs required to sustain the
business they needed a high volume of
transactions of of business to be able
to remain profitable and remain in
business but they didn't really know how
to do that
so we're working hard but we're not
placing them correctly and they're not
profitable so we're not moving the
needle at all
so with this understanding of the
problem we wanted to design profitable
or viable agent banking business and to
do this we did a compared contrast
between agents that remained around for
the Long Haul versus those that only
left after a short period to understand
the differences between them we also
literally went across the country to
understand the differences of our agents
worked across the country and understand
how money moved in the respective
communities
and with this understanding we built our
profitable agent banking model so what
are those things what are the key
elements to ensure that the agent is
viable and remains around for the Long
Haul one is you need to make sure
that you have about 500 adults you need
about 500 adults in the community to
support one of these agents so when
you're deploying overlapping agents that
can be counterproductive
another thing is even though these
agents in fact are leveraging the
internet connection to the financial
institutions online they still needed
access to cash for the community
cash was still very important
and then agent banking is not a
full-time business it's a side hustle so
you can be a bartender you can be a
grocery retailer you could be a
hairdresser anything really and offer
agent banking as an add-on to make that
viable
so we felt good that we understood how
to design it
so now we wanted to estimate how many of
these agents can we put across the
country to ensure that every Nigeria has
access to financial services universal
access
to do this it's not a simple task it
involves a lot of data so we built an
analog engine called geofin to do this
with geofan you can look across Nigeria
any part of the country and zoom in to
understand the current level of
financial access
as well as how many of these agents that
we talk about you can you need to deploy
to get to Universal coverage
so if you look down south in Nigeria in
a place called Bayelsa in Bayelsa
we have high level of financial access
about
85 percent of adults in Bayelsa have
access to financial services and so you
would only need to deploy about 2 000
more agents to get to Universal coverage
up north in Yobe though in the northeast
of Nigeria you find that about 25 only
about 25 percent of adults actually have
access to financial services and so
there you need upwards of 8 000 agents
to get to Universal coverage
quite a beautiful tool that allows us to
sort of understand and try to solve the
problem in a very nuanced way
so all of this was research and
analytics what did we find what was the
real impact of all of this
so you remember I said in Nigeria so far
we've deployed about 850 000 agents
well this approach with this approach we
discovered that we only really need
about 275 000 more agents to get
Universal coverage
now the bulk of these agents will not be
profitable in fact about 90 of them are
not profitable but that's okay
the work that you're doing is still
quite important
and so we can Subs we need to support
them with subsidies and grants to ensure
that they can stay around and support
their community
however
about 27 000 of these agents will be
profitable
we think of them as the high impact
agent and what do they do
these agents will move the needle
significantly so in Nigeria today we
estimate that only about 45 of adults
have access to financial services these
27 000 roughly agents will move the
needle from about 45 today to 80 percent
and given how fast you can deploy them
we estimate that this will occur within
24 months or less
this is the power of including the
profit motive
in development work that we can move the
needle so fast for a problem that has
remained intractable for so long
now Financial access is not the only
challenge we have what if we took the
same mindset to energy access where
instead of just deploying solar and
rural areas alone we could think about
helping entrepreneurs to build viable
Urban solar businesses
or we can also deploy this approach to
education access where instead of just
deploying schools widely we'll work with
local community entrepreneurs to build
community schools that are profitable
and viable for a long period of time
I believe that when we combine this
non-profit and for-profit approaches
when we include the profit motive in the
development work that we do
we can go fast and far together to
address these development challenges and
change the walls for the better
thank you
[Applause]